bienvenue dans « Comprendre l'information et le calcul quantiques », je m'appelle John Watrous et je suis le
directeur technique de l'éducation chez IBM Quantum. Ceci est la dernière leçon de la série et c'est la dernière leçon de la
deuxième unité de la série, qui porte sur les algorithmes quantiques. Nous avons parlé du modèle de requête du calcul, y compris les
algorithmes quantiques qui offrent des avantages prouvables sur les algorithmes classiques dans ce modèle. Nous avons abordé les concepts fondamentaux liés aux
algorithmes quantiques et à la manière de mesurer le coût computationnel, et dans la leçon précédente nous avons discuté de l'estimation de phase et de l'algorithme de Shor.
Dans cette leçon, nous allons aborder l'algorithme de Grover, qui offre un avantage quadratique du quantique sur le
classique pour ce qu'on appelle les problèmes de recherche non structurée, que je décrirai une fois qu'on sera dans la
leçon. Ce sont tous des sujets fondamentaux concernant les algorithmes quantiques. Il existe d'autres algorithmes
quantiques, ainsi que des paradigmes généraux qui unissent différents algorithmes quantiques et techniques algorithmiques quantiques, et
si tu es intéressé, je t'encourage à consulter le zoo des algorithmes quantiques, qui catégorise les algorithmes quantiques connus et inclut de nombreuses références
à des articles de recherche originaux qui ont contribué à leur développement. Pour cette série, cependant,
nous allons nous en tenir aux fondamentaux et, à partir de la prochaine leçon, nous passerons à un nouveau sujet. Mais
parlons d'abord de l'algorithme de Grover. Voici l'aperçu de la leçon. Nous commencerons par une courte discussion sur
le problème computationnel que nous allons traiter, c'est-à-dire la recherche non structurée. Intuitivement, tu peux
considérer le problème de recherche non structurée comme une recherche dans une collection d'éléments qui n'est pas triée et n'a pas été organisée de manière utile.
Ensuite, nous aborderons l'algorithme de Grover, qui est un algorithme quantique offrant un avantage quadratique sur les
algorithmes classiques, et nous verrons précisément ce que cela signifie sous peu. Une description très générale de
la façon dont cet algorithme fonctionne est la suivante : il y a d'abord une étape d'initialisation, puis une opération que j'appellerai
l'opération de Grover, qui est itérée un certain nombre de fois, et enfin une mesure qui révèle un candidat
solution au problème de recherche. Je t'expliquerai ce qu'est l'opération de Grover et comment elle peut être
implémentée sur un ordinateur quantique, puis nous analyserons cette opération pour mieux comprendre ce qu'elle fait et pourquoi elle est utile pour
la recherche. La troisième partie de la leçon porte sur le nombre d'itérations
dans l'algorithme de Grover, autrement dit le nombre de fois que l'opération de Grover doit être appliquée si l'on souhaite
maximiser la probabilité que l'algorithme réussisse à trouver ce que l'on cherche tout en minimisant son
coût. Nous commencerons par le problème de recherche unique, qui est un cas particulier dans lequel il y a exactement une solution à notre
problème de recherche, puis nous verrons ce qui se passe quand il y a plusieurs solutions. Et pour finir, je conclurai la
leçon par quelques remarques brèves sur l'algorithme de Grover et ses généralisations. Commençons par le
problème computationnel que nous allons traiter tout au long de la leçon. Tout d'abord, comme nous le faisons souvent, nous allons
laisser Sigma désigner l'alphabet binaire et nous utiliserons cette notation pour toute la leçon, donc je ne continuerai pas à
te le rappeler. Supposons que nous ayons une fonction f qui associe des chaînes binaires d'une certaine longueur n à
l'alphabet binaire. Notre hypothèse est que nous pouvons facilement évaluer cette fonction. Par
exemple, peut-être avons-nous un circuit booléen pour cette fonction dont la taille est polynomiale en n. Maintenant, cela ne signifie pas que c'est
nécessairement une fonction simple dans un sens quelconque ou que nous avons une compréhension particulièrement bonne de cette fonction. Par exemple, peut-être avons-nous un
circuit booléen assez compliqué et désordonné pour calculer f, qui nous permet de l'évaluer sur différentes chaînes d'entrée, mais qui n'a pas nécessairement une
belle forme conçue pour nous faciliter la vie. Notre objectif est de trouver une solution, c'est-à-dire
une chaîne binaire de longueur n qui amène f à évaluer à un. En général, c'est un problème computationnel très difficile,
ou du moins nous pensons qu'il est très difficile. En particulier, si l'entrée est en fait la
description d'un circuit booléen pour calculer la fonction f, alors c'est ce qu'on appelle un problème NP-complet. Une façon
de formaliser ce problème est sous forme d'un problème de requête, et en effet pour les besoins de cette leçon il est raisonnable
de penser à ce problème purement dans le contexte du modèle de requête. Mais quand on pense à où ou quand ce
problème pourrait survenir en pratique, il est sans doute plus naturel de penser à f comme étant calculée par un circuit
booléen. Comme nous l'avons vu dans la leçon six, nous pouvons relier ces deux points de vue par la construction que nous avons faite pour prendre un circuit booléen et
le convertir en un circuit quantique pour implémenter une opération de requête ou un gate de requête. Dans tous les cas, conceptuellement parlant,
l'entrée du problème est cette fonction f et nous cherchons une solution s'il y en a une. Et s'il n'y en a
pas, c'est-à-dire si f s'avère être la fonction constante zéro, alors la bonne sortie est de signaler
qu'il n'y a pas de solutions. C'est un problème de recherche non structurée dans le sens où il n'y a
rien de spécial dans f qui facilite la recherche d'une solution. Ce n'est pas comme si nous cherchions
dans des données déjà ordonnées ou chargées dans une structure de données quelconque qui faciliterait la recherche, et il n'y a aucune promesse sur la
fonction f qui pourrait nous aider. Une façon d'y penser, c'est que c'est comme chercher un
numéro de téléphone dans un annuaire téléphonique, par opposition à la recherche d'un nom, ce qui est bien plus facile à condition que les noms aient été
classés par ordre alphabétique. En termes pratiques, il ne s'agit pas vraiment de rechercher dans des données
que nous avons tendance à organiser et stocker de manière à faciliter la recherche. C'est plutôt représentatif de la recherche d'une
solution à une équation complexe, par exemple, ou peut-être de la recherche de la combinaison qui ouvre un
cadenas. En aparté, il est sensé de penser à ce problème dans le contexte du modèle de requête, quelle que soit notre opinion
sur la pertinence pratique de ce modèle. Bien sûr, il n'y a pas d'oracles ou de boîtes noires dans la vraie vie, mais jusqu'à ce que nous
apprenions le contraire, les circuits booléens compliqués et mystérieux ressemblent un peu à des boîtes
noires. Maintenant, réfléchissons aux algorithmes pour résoudre ce problème de recherche non structurée, et nous allons le faire
dans le modèle de requête, juste par souci de simplicité. Si nous avons un circuit booléen pour notre fonction plutôt qu'une boîte noire,
nous pouvons quand même exécuter des algorithmes de requête dessus. Mais bien sûr, nous ne pouvons pas exclure la possibilité qu'un nouvel algorithme
soit découvert pour ce problème qui n'est pas basé sur des requêtes, mais nous n'allons pas nous préoccuper de cette
possibilité. Premièrement, juste un peu de notation : le nombre total de chaînes d'entrée de la fonction f est 2 à la puissance
WEBVTT
n, où n est la longueur des chaînes d'entrée de f. Dorénavant, je vais laisser N en majuscule désigner ce nombre, 2 à la puissance
n. Il est assez courant d'utiliser une lettre majuscule comme celle-ci pour désigner deux à la puissance de la version en minuscule
de cette lettre. Nous allons beaucoup parler du nombre N en majuscule, donc cela va juste être
commode et aidera à garder les choses un peu plus nettes. Et encore une fois, cette notation s'applique pour
toute la leçon. Bien sûr, on peut résoudre le problème de recherche de manière classique en
itérant simplement à travers toutes les chaînes de n bits possibles dans l'ordre que l'on choisit, en évaluant f sur chacune d'elles.
Si on trouve une solution à un moment donné, on peut s'arrêter, mais dans le pire des cas, on finira par évaluer f sur chaque
chaîne d'entrée, ce qui nécessite N (c'est-à-dire N en majuscule)
requêtes. On pourrait choisir de mesurer le coût de ce calcul d'une autre manière, pas seulement en termes de nombre de requêtes, mais le nombre de requêtes
représente le nombre de fois que nous devons évaluer la fonction f, et il est raisonnable de s'attendre à ce que les évaluations de f dominent le coût
de ce calcul. C'est en fait le mieux que l'on puisse faire avec un algorithme déterministe,
et encore une fois, c'est dans le contexte du modèle de requête. Si nous avons interrogé chaque chaîne d'entrée
sauf une, et si f a pris la valeur zéro sur toutes les précédentes, comment être sûr que la dernière
chaîne n'est pas une solution ? La réponse est qu'on ne peut pas en être sûr, donc nous avons besoin de toutes les N requêtes dans le pire
des cas. Nous pourrions aussi utiliser la aléatoire, qui peut offrir quelques améliorations très mineures, comme réduire le
nombre attendu de requêtes nécessaires pour trouver une solution quand il en existe une, ou nous pourrions effectivement échanger la probabilité de
correction contre une réduction des requêtes. Mais quelle que soit la manière dont on y réfléchit, il nous faudra toujours un nombre de requêtes linéaire
en N. Donc, classiquement parlant, nous avons besoin d'un nombre linéaire de requêtes, c'est-à-dire linéaire
en N en majuscule. L'algorithme de Grover est un algorithme quantique pour la recherche qui fait mieux : il ne nécessite que O(
racine de N) requêtes. Ces requêtes se produisent en superposition, donc ce n'est pas de la magie, mais c'est
une amélioration significative par rapport à ce qui est possible classiquement, et c'est ce qu'on entend par un avantage
quadratique. Cet avantage quadratique du quantique sur le classique peut-il se transformer en un véritable avantage dans un sens pratique ?
Probablement pas de sitôt, mais dans un futur lointain, qui sait. Mais même si
l'algorithme de Grover ne conduit jamais à un avantage pratique pour la recherche, il constitue néanmoins une partie importante de
la fondation des algorithmes quantiques, qui mérite bien d'être comprise. Avant de passer à l'algorithme de Grover lui-même, nous devons
parler brièvement des gates de requête de phase. De nombreux algorithmes quantiques dans le modèle de requête s'expriment naturellement
en utilisant des gates de requête de phase, et nous verrons que l'algorithme de Grover en est un exemple
spécifique. Commençons par un aperçu rapide des gates de requête ordinaires. Pour une fonction f de
la forme dont nous parlons, le gate de requête UF est défini sur les états de base standard comme indiqué à l'écran.
Pour les superpositions des états de base standard, l'action est déterminée par la linéarité. Et il vaut la peine de rappeler
que, à partir d'un circuit booléen pour f, nous pouvons en fait construire un circuit pour cette opération UF à un coût
linéaire par rapport à la taille du circuit booléen. Le gate de requête de phase pour f, en revanche, que nous noterons par
le nom ZF, fonctionne comme ceci. En particulier, ce gate opère sur
n qubits, par opposition à n plus un qubits, et il projette automatiquement la valeur de la fonction
dans la phase, plutôt que de faire un XOR de la valeur de sortie sur un qubit supplémentaire comme nous l'avons pour
UF. Donc, si on réfléchit à ce qui se passe quand on utilise le phase kickback sur un gate UF,
on implémente essentiellement un gate ZF. Nous avons besoin d'un état moins, et cela coûte une
évaluation de UF. Mais nous récupérons bien l'état moins et pouvons l'utiliser pour la suivante si on veut, ou on peut
simplement l'ignorer. Voilà ce qu'est un gate de requête de phase. Maintenant, si nous nous
voyons simplement donner un gate de requête de phase ZF et que c'est la seule façon dont nous avons accès à la fonction f, alors nous ne pouvons pas vraiment
récupérer un gate UF. Mais si nous avons une version contrôlée de ZF, alors nous pouvons
construire un gate UF, et je te laisse celui-là comme
exercice. En plus du gate de requête de phase pour la fonction f, nous aurons aussi besoin d'un gate de requête de phase pour la fonction
OR sur n bits, autrement dit la fonction qui prend la valeur zéro lorsqu'on lui donne la chaîne de zéros et prend sinon la valeur
un. Explicitement, la façon dont ZOR fonctionne sur les états de base standard est montrée
ici à l'écran. Ce gate n'a aucune dépendance par rapport à la fonction f, donc il ne nécessite
aucune requête. Une façon de construire un circuit quantique qui implémente cette opération est de faire quelque chose
de similaire à ce que nous avons fait pour la fonction f, sauf que nous commençons avec un circuit booléen qui calcule la fonction OR sur
n bits. Maintenant que nous avons ces gates, nous sommes prêts à passer à la prochaine
section. Nous allons maintenant discuter de l'algorithme de Grover, en commençant par une description de l'algorithme. Nous commençons en initialisant
n qubits, chacun à l'état plus, autrement dit nous mettons ces qubits dans une superposition égale de toutes les
chaînes binaires de longueur n. Ce que nous allons faire en fait, c'est diriger l'état de ces qubits
vers une solution. Il est donc intuitif que nous commencions dans cet état, car nous ne savons encore rien sur la fonction f.
À ce stade, chaque chaîne est également susceptible d'être une solution, et cela se reflète par le fait que ces qubits sont dans une superposition égale de toutes les
chaînes. Puis nous itérons : nous appliquons de manière répétée l'opération de Grover, qui est vraiment le cœur de l'
algorithme, et je vais la décrire dans un instant. Nous appliquons cette opération un total de T fois, où T est un entier
non négatif. Mais ce nombre n'est en fait pas spécifié par l'algorithme lui-même ; nous devons choisir T d'une façon ou d'une autre. Dans la prochaine
section, nous allons parler des bons choix pour T. Mais pour l'instant, nous pouvons considérer ce nombre d'itérations T comme
arbitraire. Finalement, nous mesurons dans la base standard, ce qui nous donne un
candidat solution. Il n'y a aucune garantie que ce soit une solution, mais si nous choisissons T judicieusement,
la probabilité d'obtenir une solution peut être rendue grande. Et voici l'opération de Grover
WEBVTT
elle-même, que nous avons appelée G. C'est une composition d'opérations, toutes sur N qubits. Donc c'est une opération sur N
qubits. D'abord nous avons un gate ZF, autrement dit un gate de requête de phase pour la
fonction f en entrée, suivi d'une couche de gates Hadamard, puis nous avons ZOR, qui est le gate de requête de phase pour la fonction
OR, et enfin une autre couche de gates Hadamard. Nous voyons donc qu'une itération à l'
étape deux peut être implémentée par un circuit ayant la forme montrée ici à l'écran — et ici nous avons quatre qubits d'ailleurs —
mais en général nous pouvons avoir n'importe quel nombre de qubits. Un point clé à noter ici est que nous avons besoin d'une requête de f pour implémenter G.
Nous avons besoin d'une requête pour implémenter ZF, et aucune des autres opérations n'a de dépendance par rapport à f, donc elles ne nécessitent aucune requête. Donc ce nombre T qui
représente le nombre de fois que nous appliquons G à l'étape deux représente également le nombre de requêtes dont nous
avons besoin. Voici une façon typique d'utiliser l'algorithme de Grover, mais ce n'est certainement pas la seule façon. Comme je l'ai dit
précédemment, la première chose à faire est de choisir T, et nous aborderons cela dans la section suivante.
Quel que soit le T choisi, nous exécutons l'algorithme de Grover pour T itérations et nous obtenons un candidat solution
X. Il n'y a aucune garantie que X soit vraiment une solution, mais nous pouvons dépenser une requête supplémentaire pour vérifier. Si nous avons une solution, nous pouvons
la produire en sortie et nous arrêter ; sinon, nous pouvons soit réessayer, éventuellement avec un choix différent de T,
mais pas nécessairement, soit abandonner et signaler qu'il n'y a pas de solutions. Comme je l'ai dit, ce n'est
pas la seule façon d'utiliser l'algorithme, mais c'est une façon naturelle de l'appliquer au problème de recherche. Ensuite, nous allons voir ce que l'opération de Grover
fait réellement à l'état des N qubits sur lesquels elle agit. Considérons nos n qubits comme
formant un seul registre, que j'appellerai Q pour lui donner un nom. Rappelle-toi que ce qu'on fait d'abord dans
l'algorithme de Grover, c'est mettre Q dans une superposition uniforme de toutes les chaînes de n bits, et on fait ça en appliquant des gates Hadamard
à n qubits dans l'état tout-zéro. On itère ensuite l'opération de Grover G, puis on
mesure. Il sera utile de partitionner l'ensemble de toutes les chaînes de n bits en deux ensembles, A0 et
A1. A0 contient toutes les chaînes qui font évaluer f à zéro, et A1 contient toutes les chaînes qui font évaluer f
à un. Une autre façon de le dire est que A1 contient toutes les solutions à notre problème de
recherche, tandis que A0 contient toutes les non-solutions. Nous serons particulièrement
intéressés par deux états quantiques : l'un est la superposition uniforme sur toutes les non-solutions, c'est |A0⟩, et
l'autre est uniforme sur toutes les solutions, et c'est |A1⟩. Je dois souligner que ces définitions n'ont de
sens que lorsque ces ensembles sont non vides, car sinon nous sommons zéro éléments et divisons par zéro. Et en faisant
cette analyse de l'algorithme de Grover, nous allons faire cette hypothèse. Nous pouvons très facilement comprendre ce que
fait l'algorithme de Grover quand f est soit la fonction constante zéro, soit la fonction constante un, en les traitant comme des cas particuliers, mais je te laisserai
faire ça toi-même. Sans surprise, si toutes les chaînes sont des solutions, nous obtiendrons bien une
solution quand nous mesurons, et s'il n'y a pas de solutions, nous n'en obtiendrons pas, car dans ce cas il n'en existe pas.
Mais pour les besoins de cette analyse, nous allons supposer que ces deux ensembles sont non vides, de sorte que ces
définitions de ces deux états aient un sens. D'ailleurs, c'est une notation assez courante :
chaque fois que nous avons un ensemble fini non vide S, nous pouvons écrire |S⟩ pour désigner la superposition uniforme sur les
éléments de cet ensemble, comme nous l'avons ici. Rassemblons donc ces définitions comme ceci, et nous verrons comment elles se connectent
à l'algorithme de Grover. La première étape de l'algorithme de Grover est l'étape d'initialisation, qui met Q dans une superposition uniforme
sur toutes les chaînes de n bits. Pour donner à cet état un nom facilement reconnaissable, je vais l'appeler
|u⟩. U est l'abréviation de « uniforme ». Il est important pour l'analyse de noter d'abord que
cet état uniforme |u⟩ est contenu dans le sous-espace engendré par les deux vecteurs |A0⟩ et |
A1⟩. En particulier, si nous prenons la combinaison linéaire de ces deux états montrée ici à l'écran, nous obtenons |
u⟩. La clé de toute l'analyse est le fait que l'état de Q reste dans
ce sous-espace de dimension deux, peu importe combien de fois nous appliquons l'opération de Grover. Donc tout va se résumer à
ce qui se passe dans un sous-espace de dimension deux. Voyons maintenant ce que fait l'opération de Grover, et en particulier ce qu'elle
fait aux vecteurs dans le sous-espace de dimension deux engendré par |A0⟩ et |
A1⟩. Il est utile d'imaginer que G est divisé en deux parties : l'une est le gate ZF
et l'autre est le gate ZOR encadré entre deux couches de gates Hadamard.
Voici la définition de ZF telle que vue précédemment, et il est assez simple d'après cette définition de voir que son
action sur nos deux états — les superpositions uniformes des non-solutions et des solutions — consiste simplement à placer un signe moins
devant |A1⟩. Rien ne se passe pour |A0⟩, et c'est tout ce que nous avons vraiment besoin de savoir
sur ZF pour les besoins de cette analyse. Pour la deuxième partie, qui est
le gate ZOR encadré entre deux couches de gates Hadamard, commençons par rappeler comment ZOR est défini. Une façon de l'écrire
est telle que montrée à l'écran — c'est la même expression que précédemment. Une autre façon de l'exprimer en utilisant la notation directe
est comme ceci, et tu peux vérifier cette expression en réfléchissant à la façon dont l'opération à
droite agit sur les états de base standard. En particulier, elle ne fait rien à l'état tout-zéro et chaque
autre état de base standard reçoit un signe moins, ce qui est cohérent avec la définition de Z
OR. Donc, si nous encadrons cette opération entre deux couches de gates Hadamard, nous obtenons une expression similaire, sauf
qu'à la place de l'état de base standard tout-zéro, nous avons maintenant notre superposition uniforme |u⟩. Et c'est parce que H⊗n
transforme l'état de base standard |0⟩ en |u⟩, et aussi H⊗n est son propre transposé conjugué, donc cela fonctionne de
manière similaire en agissant à droite sur le bra plutôt que sur le ket. Et maintenant nous allons comprendre
ce que G fait à nos deux vecteurs |A0⟩ et |A1⟩, en utilisant les faits que nous venons d'
observer. Commençons par |A0⟩. Tout d'abord, substituons l'expression
que nous avons obtenue pour le gate ZOR encadré entre deux couches de gates Hadamard. Ensuite, nous pouvons utiliser le fait que ZF ne fait rien
WEBVTT
à |A0⟩, nous pouvons donc supprimer l'opération ZF. Maintenant, en utilisant la description
de |u⟩ que nous avons ci-dessus, ainsi que le fait que |A0⟩ et |A1⟩ sont des vecteurs unitaires orthogonaux, nous pouvons calculer
le produit de ce bra et de ce ket, et ce que nous obtenons est la racine carrée du nombre de non-solutions
divisée par N. Nous pouvons utiliser ce fait pour évaluer ce que nous obtenons, et en substituant notre expression pour |u⟩ et
en simplifiant, nous obtenons le résultat final montré ici à l'écran. Remarque en particulier que ce
vecteur est contenu dans le sous-espace de dimension deux engendré par |A0⟩ et |A1⟩, comme je l'avais suggéré, et
de plus les coefficients s'avèrent être des nombres réels. Comme toujours, vérifie cela à ton
propre rythme si tu le souhaites. J'ai tendance à passer rapidement sur ce genre de choses dans ces vidéos, avec l'
attente que tu mettras la vidéo en pause pour y réfléchir si tu le souhaites. Alors nettoyons cela pour
pouvoir sauvegarder le résultat final pour plus tard. Et maintenant nous allons faire quelque chose de similaire pour le vecteur |
A1⟩. Nous pouvons utiliser la même expression de G qu'auparavant, et cette fois le gate ZF injecte
un signe moins, ce qui est reflété ici par le fait que nous avons interverti les deux termes dans l'opération entre
parenthèses. Nous procédons ensuite de manière très similaire, et le résultat final est similaire, sauf que les deux coefficients
sont intervertis et nous avons maintenant un signe moins devant l'un d'eux, ce qui correspond simplement au résultat algébrique. Et encore une fois, tu
peux vérifier cela à ton propre rythme. Remarque qu'encore une fois nous avons une combinaison linéaire réelle de nos deux vecteurs |A0⟩ et
|A1⟩. Nous allons aussi nettoyer celui-là, et nous allons mettre le résultat final ensemble avec l'autre. Et maintenant nous pouvons voir comment G
agit sur le sous-espace engendré par nos deux vecteurs. Une façon de le faire est de l'exprimer en termes de la matrice 2×2 M qui est
montrée ici à l'écran. Pour être clair sur ce que nous faisons ici, nous associons la première ligne et la première
colonne avec |A0⟩, et la deuxième ligne et colonne avec |A1⟩. Jusqu'ici dans la série, nous avons
surtout utilisé des matrices pour décrire la façon dont les opérations agissent sur les états de base standard, mais il est courant d'utiliser des matrices
pour décrire les actions des applications linéaires sur différents ensembles de vecteurs, pas seulement les états de base standard. Et ici nous parlons de ce que fait l'opération G aux
vecteurs |A0⟩ et |A1⟩. Nous pouvons en dire plus sur ce que G fait aux vecteurs dans le
sous-espace engendré par |A0⟩ et |A1⟩ en regardant de plus près cette matrice M. En particulier, ce que nous allons trouver, c'est
que M est une matrice de rotation, ce qui signifie que son action sur cet espace de dimension deux peut être décrite comme une rotation d'un certain
angle fixe. Il y a plusieurs façons de le voir, et l'une est d'observer
que cette matrice M peut être exprimée comme le carré d'une matrice qui semble un peu plus simple. Ça peut être difficile à repérer si
on regarde juste M, mais ce n'est pas quelque chose que nous avons besoin de découvrir par nous-mêmes, nous avons juste besoin de le vérifier, et nous pouvons le faire en
élevant simplement la matrice à droite au carré. Une autre façon d'écrire la matrice à droite, sans inclure le carré, est
montrée à l'écran, et c'est la façon typique de décrire une rotation d'un angle donné Theta sous forme de
matrice. L'angle précis de rotation est l'arcsinus de la racine carrée du nombre de
solutions divisé par N. Et d'ailleurs, comme c'est la première fois que nous le voyons, soulignons que
cet angle est très important et continuera à apparaître à mesure que nous poursuivons cette
analyse. L'argument de l'arcsinus est un nombre entre 0 et 1, et plus précisément la façon dont nous
interprétons l'arcsinus ici est que c'est l'angle entre 0 et π/2 qui nous donne l'argument quand on prend
le sinus. Voilà donc une façon de penser à cette matrice que nous avons élevée au carré pour obtenir
M. Et parce qu'élever la matrice au carré revient à l'appliquer deux fois, nous voyons que M peut alternativement s'écrire comme une
rotation non pas d'un angle Theta mais de 2 × Theta, car en élevant au carré nous effectuons une rotation de Theta
deux fois. Une autre façon de tout vérifier, au cas où c'est utile, est de partir de cette expression finale de M
et d'utiliser les formules de double angle de la trigonométrie pour obtenir l'expression originale de
M. Et c'est l'expression de M qui décrit l'action que G a sur le sous-espace engendré par |A0⟩ et |A1⟩ — c'est
celle qui sera la plus utile pour la suite. Revenons maintenant à l'algorithme de Grover lui-même. Après l'
étape d'initialisation, mais avant d'effectuer toute application de G, l'état de notre registre de n qubits Q est |u⟩, la
superposition uniforme sur toutes les chaînes de n bits. Et ici nous avons la même expression de |u⟩ en termes de |A0⟩ et
|A1⟩ qu'auparavant. Mais maintenant que nous avons identifié cet angle Theta, nous voyons que nous pourrions
alternativement écrire |u⟩ comme cosinus(Theta) × |A0⟩ + sinus(Theta) × |
A1⟩. C'est clair pour le coefficient de |A1⟩, et pour l'autre coefficient, on a juste besoin de remarquer que la taille de A0 plus
la taille de A1 est N, et on peut l'obtenir par une trigonométrie de base. Voilà donc l'état avec lequel on
commence, et la première fois que nous appliquons G, nous effectuons une rotation de 2 × Theta, donc l'angle total devient 3 ×
Theta. Et si nous appliquons G à nouveau, l'angle passe à 5 Theta, car nous avons effectué une rotation supplémentaire de
2 Theta. Et ainsi de suite. Donc après T applications de G, nous pouvons représenter l'état obtenu
comme indiqué à l'écran, où l'angle de notre état est égal à (2T + 1) × Theta — c'est 2 × Theta
pour chaque application de G, plus un Theta supplémentaire car c'est l'état dans lequel on a commencé.
On peut aussi penser à l'action de l'opération de Grover en termes géométriques, ce qui aide à mettre en lumière
son fonctionnement et pourquoi son effet est de faire tourner l'état du registre Q. Voici l'idée principale : l'opération de Grover
est une composition des deux parties que nous avons déjà identifiées — l'une est ZF et l'autre est ZOR encadré entre
deux couches de gates Hadamard. Ces deux parties sont des
réflexions, et quand on compose deux réflexions on obtient une rotation. Voyons donc comment cela fonctionne en
détail. Concentrons-nous d'abord sur ZF, et nous allons restreindre notre attention au
même sous-espace de dimension deux dont nous parlons, c'est-à-dire celui qui est engendré par |A0⟩ et |
A1⟩. Comme nous l'avons déjà observé, l'action de ZF sur cet espace est assez simple : il ne fait
rien à |A0⟩ et place un signe moins devant |A1⟩. C'est une réflexion, et plus précisément
WEBVTT
c'est une réflexion par rapport à la droite parallèle à |A0⟩, que nous appellerons L1 pour lui donner un
nom. Pour voir pourquoi c'est une réflexion, il aide de dessiner une image. Voici nos deux vecteurs |
A0⟩ et |A1⟩, qui sont des vecteurs unitaires orthogonaux, et on peut imaginer que l'écran est constitué de toutes les
combinaisons linéaires réelles de ces deux vecteurs. Donc le cercle représente tous les vecteurs unitaires pour lesquels les coefficients de
ces deux vecteurs sont des nombres réels. Voici la droite L1 qui est parallèle à |A0⟩, et si l'on considère un
vecteur arbitraire S sur ce cercle, l'effet de l'application de ZF est de réfléchir par rapport à cette droite, comme illustré à l'
écran, simplement parce que nous ne faisons rien à |A0⟩ et que nous mettons un signe moins devant |
A1⟩. Dans le cas particulier où S est |A0⟩, par exemple, rien ne se passe quand on effectue cette réflexion, et quand S est
|A1⟩, la réflexion nous amène jusqu'à -|A1⟩, ce qui est cohérent avec l'action de ZF. Donc ZF est une
réflexion que l'on peut visualiser comme nous l'avons ici. La deuxième partie de G, qui est ZOR
encadré entre deux couches de gates Hadamard, peut s'exprimer comme 2 × |u⟩⟨u| moins la matrice identité, comme nous l'avons
déjà vu, et encore une fois c'est une réflexion, cette fois par rapport à la droite L2 parallèle à |u⟩ plutôt qu'à |
A0⟩. On peut visualiser cette opération de manière similaire à ZF. Voici le vecteur |u⟩,
hypothétiquement. Donc voici la droite L2 parallèle à |u⟩, et encore une fois l'action sur un vecteur arbitraire S est de le réfléchir
par rapport à la droite, qui est L2 dans ce cas.
Et enfin, comme je l'ai mentionné, chaque fois que l'on compose deux réflexions on obtient une rotation, et plus précisément c'est
une rotation de deux fois l'angle entre les droites de réflexion. Alors dessinons une image similaire
à ce que nous avions auparavant. Voici les droites de réflexion, avec l'angle Theta entre
elles. Et si l'on prend un vecteur arbitraire S, réfléchi autour de la première droite L1 puis
réfléchi par rapport à la deuxième droite L2, l'effet net sera de faire tourner le vecteur S d'un angle de deux fois Theta.
Et c'est quelque chose qui est vrai en général, et tu peux l'essayer sur d'autres exemples de ton choix pour voir que c'est bien ainsi que ça
fonctionne. En tout cas, j'espère que cela t'aide à comprendre pourquoi l'opération de Grover a l'effet de faire tourner des
vecteurs. Ensuite, nous allons aborder la question du choix du nombre d'itérations T dans l'algorithme de Grover.
Commençons par réfléchir à la façon dont l'analyse que nous avons vue jusqu'ici — qui révèle ce que fait l'opération de Grover —
quand nous l'appliquons de manière répétée à la superposition uniforme, se rapporte à la tâche que nous espérons accomplir, qui est de trouver une solution à notre problème de recherche,
ou en d'autres termes, n'importe quelle chaîne contenue dans l'ensemble A1. En bref, nous allons
fixer une cible, puis déterminer combien de fois appliquer l'opération de Grover pour s'en approcher.
Imaginons d'abord que nous avons un état quelconque qui est une combinaison linéaire de nos deux vecteurs |A0⟩ et |
A1⟩. Si nous effectuons une mesure dans la base standard sur cet état, nous allons obtenir un résultat dans l'ensemble A1, qui est
l'ensemble des solutions à notre problème de recherche, avec une probabilité égale à la valeur absolue au carré de quel que soit le coefficient que nous avons pour |A1⟩. Et pour le
vecteur montré à l'écran, ce coefficient est beta. C'est intuitif : si on mesurait l'état |A0⟩,
on obtiendrait une non-solution aléatoire, et si on mesurait |A1⟩ on obtiendrait une solution aléatoire. Donc si on mesure cet état
ici, on obtiendra une non-solution aléatoire avec une probabilité |alpha|² et une solution aléatoire
avec une probabilité |beta|². Mais nous pouvons aussi juste prendre un moment pour l'établir. Voici l'état écrit
pour que nous puissions voir quelles sont les entrées de ce vecteur pour les états de base standard. Donc si on mesure, voici les
probabilités d'obtenir chaque résultat possible, et pour obtenir la probabilité d'obtenir une solution, on somme les
probabilités de toutes les solutions possibles, ce qui nous donne la valeur absolue de beta au carré,
comme prévu. Maintenant, nous avons déjà analysé ce qui se passe quand on exécute l'algorithme de Grover pour T itérations : on obtient l'état
montré ici à l'écran. Donc parce que le coefficient de |A1⟩ est le sinus
de (2T + 1) × Theta — et encore une fois, voici cet angle Theta très important — nous
verrons une solution avec une probabilité sin²((2T + 1) ×
Theta). Nous voudrions rendre cette probabilité grande, idéalement aussi proche de un que possible. Donc en faisant tourner le vecteur d'état
en itérant G, nous allons considérer |A1⟩ comme l'état cible et essayer
de choisir T pour qu'on atterrisse près de cet état. Et en faisant cela, il est bon de garder à l'esprit que nous voudrions aussi
minimiser T, car c'est le nombre de requêtes dont nous avons besoin. Donc si on veut rendre cette
probabilité proche de un et minimiser T, il est logique d'essayer de rendre l'angle de notre vecteur d'état proche de π/2, car
c'est le plus petit angle qui rende le carré du sinus grand. Donc c'est essentiellement notre première opportunité de rendre la probabilité grande en faisant
tourner le vecteur d'état. Maintenant, nous ne pouvons pas nécessairement atteindre exactement cet angle π/2 car T doit
être un entier. Mais si on y réfléchit de manière approximative et qu'on résout pour T comme si c'était une inégalité, on voit qu'idéalement
choisir T égal à π/(4 × Theta) moins 1/2 est
logique. Mais bien sûr T doit être un entier non négatif, donc ce que nous allons faire c'est prendre
l'entier le plus proche de cette valeur idéale, c'est-à-dire le plancher de π divisé par (4 ×
Theta). Prendre le plancher signifie qu'on supprime la partie fractionnaire, autrement dit c'est le plus grand
entier inférieur ou égal à la valeur dont on prend le plancher. Selon cette expression, si la
valeur idéale se trouve exactement à mi-chemin entre deux entiers, on arrondit vers le haut, mais ça n'aura en fait aucune importance pour les
besoins de cette leçon. Alors, pour la suite, nous allons nous concentrer sur ce choix particulier de
T. Mais il y a une autre considération importante à prendre en compte, c'est que cette spécification de T dépend
du nombre de solutions qu'il y a, car l'angle Theta dépend du nombre de
solutions. Dorénavant, je vais utiliser la lettre s pour désigner le nombre de solutions, autrement dit la taille de
l'ensemble A1, juste par souci de commodité. En tout cas, l'essentiel est que notre
expression pour T — la valeur que nous supposons être bonne — dépend de Theta, et Theta dépend de s, qui est
WEBVTT
la taille de l'ensemble A1. Ce n'est pas un problème si nous savons à l'avance combien de solutions il y a. Mais
si nous ne savons pas à l'avance combien il y en a, nous ne connaissons pas Theta, donc nous ne pouvons pas choisir T de cette façon
et nous devrons faire quelque chose de différent. Je reviendrai sur la situation où nous ne connaissons pas s un peu plus tard. Mais pour
commencer, concentrons-nous sur la situation où nous savons combien de solutions il y a, en commençant par la recherche unique
où il est garanti qu'il y ait une solution unique que nous
cherchons. J'ai mentionné le problème de recherche unique comme exemple de problème de requête dans la leçon
cinq. L'entrée est une fonction f de n bits vers un bit. Il y a une unique chaîne de n bits
qui fait évaluer f à un, et l'objectif est de sortir cette chaîne. Donc
c'est équivalent au problème de recherche non structurée dont nous parlons, mais avec la promesse qu'il y a exactement une solution. Et en fait, c'est
la seule version du problème de recherche que Lov Grover a considérée dans son article original de 1996 qui a introduit l'algorithme de Grover.
Pour la recherche unique, nous avons s = 1, et donc cet angle important Theta est égal à l'arcsinus
de la racine carrée de 1/N. Quand N est grand, cette valeur est approximativement la racine carrée de 1/N, et
c'est parce que pour des angles de plus en plus petits, la fonction sinus commence à ressembler de plus en plus à la fonction
identité. Si on substitue cette approximation dans notre sélection pour T, on voit que T est approximativement le plancher
de π/(4 × √N). C'est bien parce que nous sommes en train de viser O(racine de N)
requêtes, bien qu'à ce stade nous n'ayons pas encore examiné exactement à quel point l'algorithme
fonctionne bien. Regardons un exemple où N en majuscule est 128, c'est-à-dire 2^7. Donc
notre fonction f est de sept bits vers un bit, et nous supposons qu'il y a une solution unique. Mais pour comprendre à quel point
l'algorithme fonctionne bien, nous avons seulement besoin de nous préoccuper de l'angle Theta, que nous pouvons calculer. C'est
environ 0,0885 radian, soit un peu plus de 5°. Et si on substitue cette valeur dans notre
expression pour T, on obtient huit. Donc nous réfléchissons à ce qui se passe quand on cherche une solution unique parmi 128
possibilités en utilisant huit requêtes. On peut dessiner une image pour illustrer comment l'état évolue au fil du
temps à mesure que nous effectuons des itérations de l'opération de Grover. Comme auparavant, nous avons les états |
A0⟩ et |A1⟩, et dans ce cas particulier — la recherche unique — |A1⟩ est en fait l'état de base standard
correspondant à la solution unique, quelle qu'elle soit. Et |A0⟩ est la superposition uniforme sur toutes les
chaînes sauf la solution unique. Voici la superposition uniforme sur toutes les chaînes, que nous
pouvons écrire comme cosinus(Theta) |A0⟩ + sinus(Theta) |A1⟩. Et il est logique que |A0⟩
et |u⟩ soient proches dans ce cas, car comme nous venons de l'observer, |A0⟩ est
presque la superposition uniforme sur toutes les chaînes — il ne manque qu'une seule chaîne, la solution unique. Appliquer G à nouveau effectue une rotation de
2 Theta supplémentaires. Voilà où on est après deux itérations, voici trois, quatre, cinq, six, sept et huit.
Et maintenant on voit qu'on est assez proche de |A1⟩. Donc si on s'arrête et qu'on mesure à ce stade, on sera assez susceptible d'obtenir
la solution unique. Et en fait, dans ce cas, il n'y a qu'environ une demi-chance en pourcentage de ne pas obtenir la solution
unique. D'un autre côté, si on continuait à appliquer l'opération de Grover plus que les huit fois recommandées,
la probabilité d'obtenir une solution reviendrait à la baisse, et avec le temps elle oscille à mesure que l'état tourne
autour du cercle. Il est donc important qu'on arrête les itérations au bon moment si on veut réussir avec une
forte probabilité. Réfléchissons à la probabilité que notre choix de T révèle la solution unique, de manière plus générale, pour différentes valeurs de
N. Nous allons écrire P(N,1) pour désigner la probabilité que l'algorithme de Grover réussisse à trouver une solution unique
pour chaque valeur possible de N. Le 1 signifie une solution, et nous allons étendre cette notation à d'autres nombres de solutions
sous peu. Voici un tableau de ces probabilités pour de petites puissances de deux. Il commence à N = 2, et la
probabilité est 1/2, ce qui n'est pas très bon. Mais ensuite pour N = 4, la probabilité est exactement un, donc ça fonctionne
parfaitement dans ce cas. C'est un excellent exercice d'ailleurs que de passer explicitement par comment fonctionnent ces deux cas,
et notamment le cas où N est égal à quatre. Dans ce cas, on cherche une solution parmi quatre possibilités,
on n'a besoin que d'une seule requête et ça fonctionne parfaitement. À mesure que N devient plus grand, on voit quelques fluctuations — les probabilités montent
et descendent un peu — mais elles semblent se rapprocher de un, et c'est effectivement le cas. Il est prouvable
analytiquement que la probabilité est toujours au moins 1 - 1/N. Donc c'est bien.
L'algorithme n'est pas parfait, on n'est pas garanti d'obtenir une solution, mais c'est très probable, en particulier pour de grandes
valeurs de N, ainsi que l'anomalie très intéressante qui se produit quand N est égal à 4.
Je dois aussi souligner qu'on peut toujours exécuter l'algorithme entier, y compris les mesures, autant de fois qu'on le souhaite, et si l'une des exécutions
réussit, on obtiendra une solution. Donc si ces probabilités ne sont pas assez bonnes, on peut facilement les améliorer en réexécutant simplement
l'algorithme. En fait, même si toutes ces probabilités étaient égales à 1/2 par exemple, nous aurions quand même un
algorithme de recherche utile. Voyons maintenant ce qui se passe quand il y a plusieurs
solutions. Nous commencerons par un exemple similaire au précédent : encore une fois N est égal à 128, mais cette fois le
nombre de solutions s est quatre plutôt que 1. Encore une fois, on peut calculer Theta et T, et
on obtient que Theta est environ 0,1777, soit un peu plus de 10°, et T est
quatre cette fois. L'angle est donc environ deux fois la valeur de l'exemple précédent, et T est la moitié de ce qu'il
était. On peut dessiner une image comme avant. Voici où on
commence. Voici une itération, deux, trois et quatre. Cette fois, on est très proche de |
A1⟩, et la probabilité d'obtenir une solution cette fois s'avère être supérieure à
99,9%. Mais si on ne savait pas mieux et qu'on pensait qu'il n'y avait qu'une seule solution, on prendrait T = 8 comme
auparavant, on effectuerait presque un tour complet jusqu'à -|A0⟩, et cela conduirait à une très faible probabilité de
succès. Voilà donc un autre exemple montrant qu'il y a de bons choix de T et de mauvais choix de T, et ici on voit
WEBVTT
qu'un bon choix pour s = 1 s'avère être un très mauvais choix pour s = 4. Mais en supposant qu'on connaît s
à l'avance et qu'on choisit T selon notre spécification, il s'avère que l'algorithme de Grover trouvera une solution
avec une probabilité au moins 1 - s/N, et souvent bien plus grande que ça. C'est aussi au moins s/N, mais
c'est en fait beaucoup moins intéressant. Ce qui est plus intéressant, c'est qu'à mesure que la fraction s/N devient petite, la borne
sur la probabilité de succès se rapproche de plus en plus de un. Maintenant, comme je l'ai déjà remarqué plusieurs
fois, le nombre T représente non seulement le nombre d'itérations de l'opération de Grover que nous effectuons, mais aussi le nombre
de requêtes que nous faisons. Alors, de quoi dépend ce nombre par rapport à s et
N ? Partons d'abord du fait que l'arcsinus de x est toujours au moins x, à condition que x soit entre 0 et 1.
C'est assez facile à montrer si tu connais le développement en série de Taylor de la fonction arcsinus, mais il y a d'autres façons de le raisonner, et nous allons simplement
l'accepter comme acquis car c'est vrai. Cela signifie que Theta est au moins la racine carrée de s/
N, et par conséquent T est au plus π/4 × √(N/
s). Donc c'est en fait encore mieux que O(√N) : plus s est grand par
rapport à N, moins de requêtes nous avons besoin de faire. Et d'une certaine manière, il n'est pas surprenant que cette fraction apparaisse
ainsi, étant donné que son inverse définit Theta, et qu'en fin de compte Theta est vraiment tout ce qui compte pour
cette analyse. Comme nous venons de le voir, l'algorithme de Grover fonctionne très bien quand nous connaissons
à l'avance combien de solutions il y a. Mais que faire si nous ne savons pas combien de solutions il y
a ? Il y a une approche assez simple, qui consiste à choisir le nombre d'itérations
aléatoirement. Plus précisément, choisir T uniformément au hasard entre 1 et le plancher de π/4 × √N s'avère
être une assez bonne façon de faire ça. La borne supérieure de cette plage correspond approximativement au nombre de requêtes qu'on choisirait pour la recherche unique, et en fait
c'est exactement le bon nombre dans la plupart des cas. C'est quand l'angle Theta est aussi petit qu'il peut l'être, excluant
le cas trivial où il n'y a pas de solutions. L'idée ici est qu'au lieu de viser soigneusement notre vecteur d'état vers
|A1⟩ comme on le faisait quand on savait combien de solutions il y avait, on effectue essentiellement une rotation aléatoire, comme si on donnait
au vecteur d'état une impulsion aléatoire. S'il se trouve qu'il y a exactement une solution, notre impulsion aléatoire pourrait pousser
le vecteur d'état près de |A1⟩, mais ça pourrait aussi ne l'amener qu'à mi-chemin. Et s'il se trouve qu'il y a beaucoup de solutions,
notre impulsion aléatoire pourrait potentiellement envoyer le vecteur d'état plusieurs fois autour du cercle. On ne s'attend donc pas à ce que cela révèle
une solution avec une probabilité proche de un, mais la chance que cela conduise à une solution s'il en existe une s'avère
être assez bonne : elle est toujours au moins de 40%. Ce n'est pas évident, mais c'est le
cas. Ça n'est certainement pas choquant, car un angle vraiment aléatoire aurait 50% de chances de trouver une
solution de toute façon. 40%, c'est pas mal, et rappelle-toi qu'on peut toujours augmenter la probabilité de trouver une solution en
répétant le processus, en choisissant T indépendamment à chaque fois. En faisant cela, les chances de ne pas
trouver de solution quand il en existe une décroissent exponentiellement avec le nombre de répétitions. Donc si on veut une probabilité de 99%
de trouver une solution, on peut exécuter cette approche simple 10 fois, encore une fois avec T choisi indépendamment à chaque
fois. Naturellement, si on ne trouve pas de solution, on sort « pas de solutions ». S'il n'y a pas de solutions,
on n'en trouvera pas, donc dans ce cas on sortira toujours la bonne réponse, c'est-à-dire « pas de solutions ». S'il y a des solutions, on pourrait
échouer à en trouver une et déclarer incorrectement qu'il n'y en a pas, mais la probabilité que cela se produise peut être rendue très petite.
Nous avons aussi, comme je l'ai mentionné il y a quelques instants, que cela nécessite un nombre de requêtes ou d'évaluations de f qui est O(racine de
N). Donc en utilisant l'algorithme de Grover, on peut quand même résoudre le problème de recherche avec une forte probabilité en O(racine de N)
requêtes, même si on ne sait pas à l'avance combien de solutions il y a. Il y a aussi une approche plus sophistiquée
qui peut conduire à une réduction du nombre de requêtes à mesure que le nombre de solutions augmente. Je ne la décrirai pas en
détail, et à la place je vais juste me concentrer sur l'idée principale. Nous commençons avec T en majuscule égal à
un. Nous exécutons ensuite l'algorithme de Grover pour un nombre aléatoire d'itérations, mais où la borne supérieure est T. Donc la première
fois qu'on arrive à l'étape deux, on va exécuter l'algorithme de Grover avec une itération, mais T va
augmenter. Si on trouve une solution, on la sort et on s'arrête. Et si on ne trouve pas de solution, on rend T
plus grand et on réessaie. Et à un moment donné, avant que T ne devienne trop grand, on terminera le processus et
on déclarera qu'il n'y a pas de solutions. C'est la même idée de base que dans l'approche simple, où on donne
des impulsions aléatoires au vecteur d'état, mais ici on commence d'abord par des impulsions plus légères quand T est
petit, au cas où il y aurait beaucoup de solutions. De cette façon, on ne gaspillera pas de requêtes en faisant tourner l'état
encore et encore autour du cercle en tournant trop fort. Mais si ça ne fonctionne pas — c'est-à-dire si on ne trouve pas de solution — on réessaie
mais on tourne un peu plus fort, ou potentiellement un peu plus fort. Pour que ça fonctionne, le taux d'
augmentation de T doit être choisi soigneusement, et une façon de le faire fonctionner est de remplacer T par le plafond de (5/4) × T.
Donc T augmente de manière exponentielle, et intuitivement on peut y penser comme tourner 25% plus fort à chaque
fois. Et il est important pour l'analyse que T augmente de manière exponentielle comme ça. Pourquoi 5/4 pourrait-on demander ? Eh bien, c'est juste
un nombre qui fonctionne, et il y a en fait une plage de valeurs qui fonctionnent, mais deux ne fonctionne pas par exemple — doubler T
à chaque fois est une augmentation trop rapide pour profiter pleinement des avantages des impulsions plus légères. De toute façon, l'essentiel de cette méthode plus
sophistiquée est qu'elle donne la même borne asymptotique sur le nombre de requêtes nécessaires qu'auparavant :
O(√(N/s)). Mais on n'a pas besoin de savoir à l'avance combien de solutions il y a. Et d'ailleurs,
on peut arrêter ce processus quand T atteint √N. Donc s'il n'y a pas de solutions, on arrivera à cette conclusion après O(
racine de N) requêtes. Et c'est ainsi qu'on peut choisir le nombre d'itérations dans l'algorithme de Grover. Pour conclure la leçon, je vais
faire juste quelques remarques brèves sur l'algorithme de Grover. Premièrement, dans le modèle de requête,
l'algorithme de Grover est asymptotiquement optimal. Ce que cela signifie, c'est qu'il est impossible de concevoir un
algorithme de requête pour résoudre le problème de recherche — ou même le problème de recherche unique spécifiquement — qui utilise asymptotiquement
WEBVTT
moins de O(√N) requêtes dans le pire cas. C'est quelque chose qui peut être prouvé rigoureusement,
et il existe en fait plusieurs preuves connues de ce fait. Il est intéressant de noter que cela était connu
avant même que l'algorithme de Grover soit découvert. L'algorithme de Grover a correspondu à la borne inférieure déjà connue sur le nombre de
requêtes nécessaires. De temps en temps, des gens proposent des approches qu'ils pensent être asymptotiquement
supérieures à l'algorithme de Grover, mais il y a toujours soit une erreur, soit une hypothèse sur la fonction f et
la façon dont on peut y accéder, ou quelque autre problème qui rend la déclaration incorrecte. Si tu travailles correctement
dans le modèle de requête, tu ne peux pas battre l'algorithme de Grover pour la recherche non structurée. Deuxièmement, l'algorithme de Grover est
assez largement applicable, dans le sens où l'accélération par racine carrée qu'offre l'algorithme de Grover pour le problème de recherche non structurée peut être
obtenue dans une variété de contextes différents. Par exemple, il est parfois possible d'utiliser l'algorithme de Grover en
plus d'un autre algorithme pour obtenir une amélioration quadratique au-delà des performances de cet algorithme. L'algorithme de Grover est aussi
très couramment utilisé comme sous-routine à l'intérieur d'autres algorithmes quantiques. Comme exemple simple, on peut
utiliser l'algorithme de Grover pour obtenir un avantage quadratique sur les algorithmes classiques pour le problème du minimum que j'ai mentionné dans la
leçon cinq. Et enfin, la technique utilisée dans l'algorithme de Grover — où on a deux
réflexions qui sont composées et itérées pour faire tourner un vecteur d'état quantique — peut être généralisée de façon
assez importante. Un exemple est une technique connue sous le nom d'amplification d'amplitude, où un processus
qui généralise l'algorithme de Grover peut être appliqué à un autre algorithme quantique pour essentiellement booster sa probabilité de succès quadratiquement plus vite que
ce qui serait possible classiquement. Cette technique a de larges applications dans les algorithmes quantiques. Donc il est peut-être vrai que
l'algorithme de Grover ne conduira probablement pas à un avantage quantique pratique de sitôt, voire jamais. Mais l'algorithme de Grover est
sans aucun doute un algorithme quantique fondamentalement important et largement applicable, et il est représentatif d'une technique plus générale qui a de nombreuses
utilisations. Et c'est tout pour cette leçon et pour cette unité de la série, qui a porté sur les algorithmes
quantiques. Nous avons abordé le modèle de requête et comment le relier à un modèle de calcul plus standard, ainsi que
d'autres concepts fondamentaux concernant la façon dont on peut mesurer le coût computationnel. Nous avons ensuite couvert l'estimation de phase,
la factorisation, et enfin l'algorithme de Grover. Comme je l'ai déjà suggéré,
il y a beaucoup plus à apprendre sur les algorithmes quantiques, mais dans cette série nous allons passer à un sujet différent dans la prochaine unité. En particulier, nous allons
examiner la formulation générale de l'information quantique, où les états quantiques sont représentés par des matrices d'un certain
type, appelées matrices densité. Comme nous le verrons, cette formulation s'avère très utile, et en effet
indispensable pour comprendre certains aspects de l'information quantique. Et elle s'avère aussi être assez belle d'un
point de vue mathématique. J'espère donc que tu te joindras à moi pour l'unité trois, et au revoir jusqu'à
là.